all right hey palsies my name is cody
and i'm a helpster that means a monster
who helps and because i love love love
to help so much i'm making these videos
called helpsters
help you
i love spending time with my friends mr
prim and scatter and heart but even when
we're apart we still find ways to be
together like
we send each other cards
and handmade little presents heart sent
me this painting hey i'm wearing the
same outfit huh
you can send your friends and family
cards and drawings too or you can talk
on the phone or video chat or even read
books to each other or you can do what
my friends and i do and oh
wait i'll show you
mr prim speaking
mr prem it's cody
my dear cody wonderful to hear from you
oh you too
oh
let me get heart and scatter on the
phone too
great hello
hearts residents heart speaking ah heart
and scatter it's cody all right
hello cody my friend hi palsy hi buddy
and mr prim remains on the phone as well
great hey is everybody ready to make a
new song i can't wait oh yes yes yes
indeed absolutely okay great now you all
make the music and i'll sing the words
oh i will start
[Music]
it sure feels like we're together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're so wonderful
hey thanks for watching i'll be back
soon and until then see what you can do
to help the people and the monsters
around you because everyone loves a
helping hand say goodbye everybody
help you